es un hecho eso sí no está firmado Y es
que así mismo lo ha explicado Messi hace
tan solo unos minutos como decías a un
medio de comunicación español y es que
el jugador no puede firmar todavía
ningún contrato nuevo dado que hasta el
30 de junio sigue siendo jugador del
París Saint Germain tras un mes de
especulaciones sobre Su futuro el mismo
ha confirmado que tras su inminente
fichaje como es bien estabais diciendo
ya anunciado en dos medios de
comunicación y a ti en este momento se
está haciendo eco todo el planeta
podemos decir va a ser refinado por la
msl Major League Soccer también a modo
informativo les cuento Que la msl pass
es una plataforma donde en Estados
Unidos se puede ver en la liga de fútbol
las razones de esta decisión bueno el
ácido bastante contundente en esa
primera entrevista que ha dado a los
medios españoles Y es que se ha
decantado por esta oferta de Florida que
lo quiere llamar su nueva casa aceptando
una oferta de 50 millones de dólares en
contraposición a los 300 millones que
llegó a ofrecer el equipo de Arabia
saudí las razones principales que le han
hecho decidirse por la ciudad de las
palmeras por Miami bueno dice que la
calidad de vida que también Busca
tranquilidad y que sus hijos su familia
se adapten a este nuevo ambiente y el
vivir con menos presión su experiencia
en el fútbol en esta nueva temporada
también por cierto se añaden paquetes
extra como la participación en las
acciones del club además de una serie de
sponsors
muy importantes como sería la marca
Adidas además también el jugador tenía
claro lo dijo en ocasiones que su
próximo destino sería o España o Estados
Unidos como bien sabemos el Barcelona no
pudo hacer una oferta a su nivel Así que
finalmente lo recibiremos en Florida
Pero eso sí la oferta